vamos con el problema 42 en el problema
42 nos dan un sistema de ecuaciones la
primera ecuación es x menos 4 igual a
zeta la segunda ecuación es menos x
igual a 8 y la tercera ecuación es 8 - z
igual a 8 menos zeta igual a t y lo que
nos piden es determinar el valor de z
cuál es el valor de c está muy bien las
opciones de información son las
siguientes el enunciado 1 es que x es
igual a 7 x es igual a 7 bueno si
sabemos que x es igual a 7 podemos
sustituir en la primera ecuación y nos
quedaría que 7 menos 4 o sea 3 es igual
a z entonces con el inciso 1 podemos
determinar el valor de zeta así solito
vale entonces bueno incluso en contra el
valor de z no tenía que hacerlo pero
bueno ya lo hice mi modo louis en
automático y el inciso 2 el inciso 2 lo
que dice es que te es igual a 5 t es
igual a 5
latte aparece por acá entonces
conociendo el valor de t aquí tendríamos
8 menos z igual a 5 y de ahí podemos
despejar se está vale entonces el inciso
2 también sirve por sí mismo para
determinar el valor de z y por lo tanto
la respuesta es de cualquiera de los dos
incisos por si mismo sirve para
responder el problema vamos ahora vamos
ahora con el 43 que voy a hacer en color
naranja y el 43 nos pregunta si x es
igual a 5 x es igual a 5 x es igual a 5
ok
como información en el inciso 1 tenemos
que x es mayor o igual que 5
x es mayor o igual que 5 esta
información por sí misma no nos permite
determinar si x 5 por ejemplo x podría
ser 8 o 23 o bueno puede ser 5 pero por
sí misma no nos permite determinar vale
entonces vamos al 2 en el 2 nos ponen x
es menor o igual que 5 a pues con ésta
ya le hicimos verdad bueno por sí misma
no otra vez nada más esta información no
nos permite decidir si x 5 porque x
podría ser tres o menos 21 o 5 entonces
con ésta no se puede pero si juntamos
las dos x tiene que ser mayor o igual
que 5 y menor o igual que 5 entonces x
queda atrapado verdad a fuerza tiene que
ser 5 entonces por sí mismas no
funcionan pero si juntamos las dos si
podemos responder esta pregunta entonces
tendríamos que la respuesta es sí muy
bien vamos ahora con el 44 que voy a
hacer en color verde hace mucho que no
utilizo este este color verde que está
bien padre en el 44 tenemos que hacer
una tabla con información la voy a poner
por aquí
entonces tenemos esta tabla
está un poquito grande y aquí arriba
tenemos algunas letras r r cd&v y aquí
también r s t y quién sabe de qué se
trate ahorita lo leemos además aquí nos
ponen un cero una y una equis 162 ok 10
0 56 y 0 56 56 y por acá 75 luego aquí
nos ponen x 56 50 y 60 y 69 y finalmente
aquí abajo nos ponen 62 62 75
69 69 y 0 muy bien tenemos esta tabla de
ahí voy a leer el problema nos dice la
tabla esta tabla de aquí nos muestra la
distancia en kilómetros por la ruta más
directa entre cualesquiera dos ciudades
rst
por ejemplo la distancia entre la ciudad
r r y la ciudad es 62 kilómetros
entonces r conduce 62 r con 162 muy bien
eso tiene sentido que conteste 0 claro
una ciudad consigo misma esta distancia
a cero va entonces lo que nos preguntan
es cuál es el valor de x cuál es el
valor de x entonces queremos determinar
este valor de acá o bien este valor de
acá bueno que son del mismo verdad es la
distancia de r
atte entonces las opciones que tenemos
son 1
uno por la ruta más directa la distancia
entre ese ítem es el doble de la
distancia entre ese y r entonces este es
el doble de la distancia s r vamos a ver
esto que nos dice con respecto a la
tabla a ver este es 56 56 y 56 es igual
al doble de ese ere ese ere o bien rs o
sea es igual a 2 veces y entonces esto
nos da una ecuación en verdad de hecho
nos dice que es igual a 28 dividiendo
entre 2 pero esto no nos dice nada
acerca de x entonces esta información
por sí misma pues no no tiene nada de
sentido con respecto a x y en el 2 nos
dice que por la ruta más directa la
distancia entre t 1 t
es igual a 1.5 veces
la distancia entre r y la distancia
entre rate muy bien vamos a leer la
tabla para ver qué nos dice eso la
distancia entre t
osea 69 69 es igual a 1.5 veces la
distancia de r
a eso justo es x es 1.5 x entonces está
ya casi nos va a permitir determinar el
valor de x no lo voy a hacer porque los
números ya se pusieron feos y no
necesitamos hacerlo solo nos basta con
saber que esta de aquí es suficiente
entonces la respuesta sería b b eso
quiere decir el inciso 2 es suficiente
pero el 1 no muy bien vamos ahora al
problema 45 que voy a hacer pues digamos
en este color rojo problema 45 y dice lo
siguiente dice cuál es el valor del
entero de dos dígitos x entonces tenemos
un entero de dos dígitos dígitos que se
llama x vamos a ponerle a x
que está formado por los dígitos ahí ves
sale aquí iverson dígitos bueno entonces
la información 1 nos dice que la suma de
los dígitos es 3 nos dice que además ven
es igual a 3 eso no nos dice gran cosa
verdad hay varias posibilidades todavía
no podemos determinar x con precisión
por ejemplo x podría ser 21 o 12 ó 30
creo que son todas las posibilidades que
hay pero bueno todavía no podemos
determinar x con esta información vamos
al inciso 2 el inciso 2 nos dice que x
es divisible entre 3 x es divisible
visible entre 3 bueno pues aquí el truco
es que un número es divisible entre 3
cuando la suma de sus dígitos es
divisible entre 3 entonces celia los los
de arriba funcionan pero hay muchos más
múltiplos de 3 verdad aquí abajo también
funcionaría a 48 o 60 ó 33 cualquier
múltiplo de 3 vale que sea de dos
dígitos bueno a ver la información 1 no
es suficiente y la información 2 tampoco
o sea juntando las dos no tenemos mucho
más porque otra vez caemos en estos
casos entonces incluso juntando la
información 1 y la información 2
no podemos deducir el valor de x y por
lo tanto aquí la respuesta sería y la
respuesta es
vale la respuesta es que este truco es
muy útil que un número sea divisible
entre 3 cuando la suma de sus dígitos es
divisible entre 3 pero bueno ahorita no
nos sirvió para determinar x bueno vamos
finalmente al problema 46 el problema 46
que dice lo siguiente nos preguntan cuál
es el dígito de las décimas en la
representación de un cierto número
aunque entonces el dígito de las décimas
el número es algo algo algo punto y nos
interesa este dígito de acá voy a
ponerle un triangulito algo algo algo
entonces nos preguntan por este dígito
de aquí va en el enunciado 1 la
información que nos dan es que el número
es menor que un tercio dejar de ponerle
x entonces x es menor que un tercio y un
tercio es pues 0.3 33 está tan bueno
y en el inciso 2 nos dicen que x es
mayor que un cuarto x es mayor que un
cuarto y esto es 0.25 vale entonces esta
información por sí misma pues no nos
permite determinar esto verdad el número
podría ser 0.1 o 0.2 o 0.3 hasta ahorita
no no podemos determinar el valor de
triángulo con la información del inciso
2 tampoco si x le gana a un cuarto
entonces pues el número podría ser pues
0.7 o 0.8 o 1.45 entonces pues no
sabemos nada de este dígito bueno de
este dígito triangulito y si combinamos
las dos que sucede si combinamos esta
con esta sigue habiendo ambigüedad creo
que sí verdad o sea a lo mejor hay
números que cumplen las dos cosas pero
tienen tienen dígitos aquí en las
décimas distintos por ejemplo el 0.32 es
menor que un tercio y es mayor que un
cuarto pero aquí triangulitos sería 3
y el 0.26 también es mayor que un cuarto
y menor que un tercio 0.26 pero aquí el
triangulito sería 2 entonces pues no no
ni siquiera juntando este la información
en los dos enunciados podemos determinar
el valor de triangulito y entonces aquí
la respuesta también sería y la
respuesta es e y eso quiere decir que ni
siquiera juntando la información de uno
y dos podemos responder la pregunta que
nos hace